so we just got out of the game awards
we're here above planet hollywood above
where they were doing the the show
itself
and i i think the thing that stole the
show for everybody i mean the reason
they saved it for last was the legend of
zelda wii u ah amazing now we haven't
seen that since e3 right we saw that
clip of him just sitting on opponent in
the field but this time we got to see
him actually riding epina yeah and we
got to see the world itself which is
something that you're gonna see freaking
enormous they're obviously taking a lot
of pages from books like uh elder
scrolls from far cry i mean you saw him
jump off of a ledge and just like pull
up like a paracel he's gonna glide down
it's the leaf from wind waker he's got
the he's got the paracel and the other
cool thing a lot of stuff from shadow of
mordor the jumping the jumping he's got
this new move where he can actually
vault off the back of the horse and goes
into slow motion and he can like target
and uh pick a target and hone in on an
enemy and then pull back his bow and
just
and it's awesome
it's awesome those are all things that
we've wanted to see from a zelda game
for for so long i mean they're always
good they're always kind of an open
world experience but this is basically
saying no this is an open world this
could potentially be like the the
original game which was literally an
open world where you could explore
things out of order just do whatever you
wanted and it gives you that feeling of
maybe it's going to be like that and of
course getting to see opponent always
makes everybody happy there were two
there were two worse confirmed two
horses zelda and uh i think a little bit
of a meme started with this one
so uh real horses don't run into trees
they were
explaining that uh epona now you can
actually you can guide her using the wii
u thumbstick but alanuma was barely
touching it which makes me think that
when you're on epina she automatically
runs and you just sort of guide her in
the direction you want her to go and
she'll run automatically kind of like
the boat and wind maker you set it on at
salem it does whatever and uh she won't
run into trees now and they said you
know oh real horses don't run into trees
so that's like
the new meme upon is now a real horse
because she no longer will run into
trees and there's going to be a lot of
really cool stuff to explore i mean it's
a big open world and it looks like
they were discovering things as they
went along they looked off in the
distance and they saw like what's the
that's in a waypoint of that tower like
if you can see it you can go there which
sunset too it's not the first time we've
seen any of these kinds of things in
games but when you put that nintendo
touch that little little bit of like
it's like a disney magic when you put
that on there oh
it's so exciting and it just looked like
beautiful those like the green and the
hills and he was standing on the cliff
and looking out like it reminded me a
lot of skyward sword but it's but at the
same time it sort of had this like
almost like majora's mask ocarina field
because it looked like that old ancient
hyrule i'm really uh excited to see
where it sort of sits in the legend of
zelda timeline because they've gone back
with skyward sword which is like the
origin story i guess and they've brought
it and then there's like three branching
timelines or whatever so i'd love to see
where this one goes that is going to
have a lot of fans probably arguing on
the internet
even once they reveal it to you know
talking about how that actually fits in
and i can't believe we're getting this
in 2015 along with majora's mask so two
zelda titles in the same year and star
fox they said that star fox will be
coming out before the wii u zelda comes
out and then we also get code name steam
in march so it's mario maker code names
team star fox and wii u zelda next year
sounds like a really great year for
nintendo it's going to be hard to choose
a wii u game of the year next year but
it's probably zelda probably
you